on you
nice cool
yeah we'll look at at dali too
uh it just came out 10 minutes ago
this is by open ai if you want to
investigate yourself this is just the
open ai blog i have not seen
this yet so legit this is
the the first time i'm seeing it as well
if you see something cool let me know in
in the chat also i have no clue
new camera
very wide angle makes my arms really
long see really long arms
excellent
all right i mean we'll we'll just dive
in right uh so
we'll read this together as i said i
have like this is the first time i'm
seeing this as well so
um yeah
new ai system that can create realistic
images and art from a description in
natural language
that sounds interesting
so and this is typical open ai blog
right where they they just have their
examples like there's no way you're
going to interact with this
i i guess
there's also a paper so um
they don't even put this on archive
right like their papers they're just on
their own website they're so they're so
famous hierarchical text conditional
image generation with clip latency so
i've he like i think
um
let's search diff
diffusion models so
yeah
so this is now not no longer based i
think this is now based on diffusion
models which was to be expected
sorry estrus this is not live coding
we'll just we'll just look at
this new research that just came out and
we'll react to it in the moment
so
um
an astronaut riding a horse in a
photorealistic style okay so this
it can create original realistic images
and art from a text description can
combine content concepts attributes
styles so this is what we're used to i
guess from the image generation
models but this obviously so dali was
always it's different than the clip
notebooks and so on the air that you're
used to because those are all those are
all
mainly clip based and then you put some
kind of a model in front of clip and you
optimize the whole thing but um
the ali is a a forward so you input the
text and then there's a forward
propagation and then the the result is
an image and that's may or may not be
filtered so uh teddy bears
shopping for groceries
as a one-liner this is insane so this is
what this model can do and there there's
a bunch of different images right here
now these are
well if they're not cherry picked at
least they're curated right so they they
want to see that nothing
um nothing bad happens when you look at
these things
a bowl of soup
that looks like a monster's
what is this please please come on
okay this is insane
um
really insane
knitted out of wool
made out of
spray painted on a wall
wow
i mean
yeah it depends how cherry-pick these
things are but this is really impressive
now i don't know if you've seen but
there is kind of a new
uh lion plus clip notebook or something
lion clip
um
of
diffusion
let's just search for that
because
because this is also is very
like there's a new notebook
um
and i've seen this around twitter yeah
exactly there's this new notebook this
is not by open ai this is in clip that
has been trained on this open source
data set and when people combine this
with these kind of old methods of
clipped notebooks then this is what
happened so this is uh
like weird and it's it's funny because
it can spell but it kind of um
it is like it is not
it doesn't spell really well but if you
so there is this
um
this research here and these are already
quite insane in quality right latin and
diffusion
i like i love generative models that's
actually good
uh a painting of a squirrel eating a
burger but now we're we're at this dulli
so these seem to be very
very uh much better now this model is
based on diffusion which means that it
has some interesting capabilities if you
know diffusion models technically what
they do is
uh they are creating their own data set
in in the sense that
a diffusion model essentially
iteratively refines a piece of input in
multiple steps until it reaches the
output so it's not necessarily one
forward
propagation although it depends a little
bit on how you model it you can have one
layer for each of the denoising steps or
you can have the same neural network and
you pass the input over and over again
maybe with some indication of what time
step it is
so what a diffusion model does it it
takes an image
and it just adds noise to it step by
step so it adds a bit of noise and it
takes that it adds a bit of noise it
takes that
until it is completely garbage like
until it is complete noisy and at that
point
you can reasonably assume
by some some limit theorem that this is
now
perfectly modeled by a
gaussian noise or whatever noise you use
and because of that because you have a
process that results in a defined
distribution you can sort of make
reverse inferences mathematically which
leads to some
training properties that you can then
use to train these diffusion models in
practice what that means is that you
take an image you make it continuously
more noisy that's your training set and
what you train is the reverse so you
train always to go from one step in this
denoising process to go to the little
bit less noisy version of that image so
that's what you train so this this
direction is easy right to make it more
noisy but then you train a neural
network to make it always one step less
noisy and that essentially means that
you can now sample the the original
thing which you know is a gaussian so
you can sample from that and then you
can send it through all of these stages
of denoising and at the end you'll end
up with a really nice picture and you
can do that conditionally on text which
is what they do here now given that this
is what they do they have some
interesting capabilities notably they
can edit images so they can start with
an image and then edit that image and
they can even edit only parts of that
because they can mask some of the parts
and then simply apply the
denoising diffusion process to that um
so that's that's what they do right here
now i am going to if you don't mind just
uh quickly
um
uh put on twitter that i'm live
streaming right here and maybe also on
discord i hope this opens over here
yes
one second nope
yep
all right
uh
[Music]
just so just writing the the
announcement adding the little picture
picture
and off we go
all right yeah so um
they can edit so now let's see
make realistic edits to existing images
from a natural language caption and this
i think is what really will make a
difference in sort of ai
art
what they say we use diffusion models
for the decoder and experiment with both
auto aggressive and diffusion models for
the prior
is my mic muted is my mic muted
no i think i just made the twitter
announcement and then i was quiet for 10
seconds sorry all right let's see so you
can
um
make edits so what they do is here's the
original image
and
they s they select a location where they
want to edit as i said you can edit
images and you can do so in a
constrained way
and one is so you can select the
location and you can prompt it to add a
flamingo right that's the natural
language prompt is to add a flamingo and
you select the location where you want
to add a flamingo look at this this is
insane look at these results
add a flamingo to this
okay
it's interesting that that the flamingo
style right matches the rest of the
picture it's not just a flamingo when
it's inside it's this sort of
what is this even like is this a piece
of furniture or so like this isn't or or
a a
sort of a swimming device flamingo yet
when it's when you select the
when you select it on the water as well
but when you select it outside it's
actually real flamingo
so this is this is quite
quite insane it doesn't just add a
flamingo it actually takes the entire
picture into account
let's say
add a corgi again so this is the
original image on the left and then you
select the location and the prompt is to
add a corgi
now
notice that the style of the corgi
changes depending on where it is right
the left is is this the is this like the
self portrait of
is this the self portrait of fungo i'm
not sure
but
um
and if you add the corgi here it's
actually real corgi right so
it's super powerful because it it looks
beyond like it it uh
swimming device fling i'm sorry i don't
know what it's called
so
yeah you can see this is this is all a
real corgi whereas where if you go into
the if you point into the image it
actually matches the style of the of the
image drawn so this is
this is super like
this
demonstrates quite a bit of
understanding i believe at least like
integration
integration uh of the entire thing this
is going to be a paid service isn't it i
look i don't know because the
interesting thing is they didn't even
make dolly into a paid service until now
and because they withheld dolly we got
all of this you know vqgan plus clip and
diffusion models plus clip things which
is
like i don't think that would have
happened if they were just to release
dali even as a paid service let's see
what else they have here so we add a
sofa
yeah i so i think this is going to be
quite huge for
for making and making any any sort of
visuals like if i you know i i need to
make thumbnails for these videos and all
so
um
if if you do anything like this this is
essentially it is a
let's say a weak
weak form of photoshop but that's
automatic so
if you
you know you could you could give this
to someone on fiverr and that's about
what it would turn out right you could
give the picture on the left and be like
i'd like to add a sofa in in the back
corner there please do it
and
that'll cost you i don't know 20 bucks
50 bucks or so on fiverr um
and
this just works so yeah i'm excited to
see what they do with it because they do
they do have a
like investors and so on
can take an image and create different
variations of it inspired by the
original
yeah so this is this is essentially
different variations i don't know what
they prompted with here
they don't say as far as i can tell
but
maybe they just
they just
maybe what they do is they they sort of
back propagate it
um or they noise it a bit and then they
denoise again from the intermediate
stage so with these diffusion models
right you can
make an image more noisy maybe change it
a little bit in some intermediate layer
and then use the diffusion models again
to upscale it
and maybe that's how they do these types
of things i'm not sure they don't they
don't say right here maybe they say in
the paper
uh this is though fairly interesting
uh you can see that there's two two
people on the left is this klimt i'm not
sure i'm not an artist person thing
um
image to text embedding to image
that could be
that could be
but you can see that
it is not it is like the
the variations are really
keeping sort of the semantic content
here and i believe that's also one of
the powerful things
of the oh
that's one of the powerful things of
training image and text together because
text by nature of being made for humans
to communicate with each other a text is
much more on the level
of sort of the
i should say this uh the type of
information and degradation of
information that is important to humans
so
training image and text together i
believe just by the nature of having the
text in there will will give
representations that are much closer to
what humans would consider different or
relevant or something like this like
this is i mean this come on this is
insane look at that
look at that wow
i think it's taking the generated
embedding and then regenerating the
image from that embed yeah yes exactly
so they they
oh you believe okay maybe they run it
through the encoder they don't actually
noise it
that's very possible yeah
would this be possible with audio i
guess yeah you'd have to find a relevant
noising process i'm not sure if gaussian
noise or so is really
appropriate for audio but since this
since audio is a continuous uh
continuous signal i don't see why this
wouldn't be possible with audio
especially if you train it with
associated with text right
i mean
yeah
this is crazy it would be really
interesting to see if um
sort of the representations of this
stuff aligns with the representations of
like real pictures of birds or if they
are way
way different because you can see here
these style variations they all
they all depict the same subject and
they are kind of in the same style
right
um it'd be interesting to see how much
it can actually differentiate
differentiate that from
it
it's also interesting that here they
have these um these colored boxes in
there
so
do you think this might be the
is this is this an artifact of what is
this like an artifact of degeneration
process like is this the they sample
other aggressively
are they always the same
yellow
light blue green red blue
yellow light green green red blue
i can't tell what they are
look at that i mean yeah this is like
just a level of the level of abstraction
and and
i'm not sure what people like like gary
marcus make of this this would be
super interesting to hear because
i mean look at that so there is
it is clearly not a natural picture
right it's it's not
yet it depicts a girl with headphones on
the laptop
like in
apparently in some sort of garden or
surrounded with plants
overlooking a city in the night sky with
the moon
and there's a cat in it
and all of that is
in all of these pictures however
it's
just different right
it's a bit look at like
you you can't tell me that this thing
doesn't do
some degree of abstraction
or it just brute forces all of this by
training data but i can
hardly imagine
so you know
one second
has learned the relationship between
images and the text used to describe
them it's used a process called
diffusion which starts with a pattern of
random dots gradually alters the pattern
towards an image when it recognizes
specific aspects so yeah as for people
who tuned in late diffusion models they
create training data by making pictures
more and more noisy
so they learn to reverse say reverse
that noise
let's see
well
um can you hear you probably can't hear
that sound right
so yeah no
no okay
let me quickly try
how about this bot painted like a
picasso now i can't hear it all right
one second
um
yep this one
didn't think so dolly 2 is a new ai
system from open ai that can take simple
text descriptions like a koala dunking a
basketball and turn them into photo
realistic images that have never existed
before
dolly 2 can also realistically edit and
retouch photos based on a simple natural
language description it can fill in or
replace part of an image with ai
generated imagery that blends seamlessly
with the original it's called in
painting
in january 2021 openai introduced dolly
a system that could generate images from
text like this avocado armchair
dolly 2 takes the technology even
further with higher resolution greater
comprehension and new capability here's
a video idea i built a real life avocado
arm chair
let's do that that's a future video
promise
i should promise things like this
okay promise
like in painting it can even start with
an image as an input and create
variations with different angles and
styles
dolly was created by training a neural
network on images and their text
descriptions
through deep learning it not only
understands individual objects like
koala bears and motorcycles but learns
from relationships between objects
and when you ask dolly for an image of a
koala bear riding a motorcycle and knows
how to create that or anything else with
a relationship to another object or
action
the dolly research has three main
outcomes first it can help people
express themselves visually in ways they
may not have been able to before
second an ai generated image can tell us
a lot about whether the system
understands us or is just repeating what
it's been taught
dolly helps humans understand how ai
systems see and understand our world
this is a critical part of developing ai
that's useful and safe the technology is
constantly just looking like an app
if it's taught with images that are
incorrectly labeled like a plane labeled
car and a user tries to generate a car
dolly may create a plane it's like
talking to a person who learned the
wrong word for something
dolly can also be limited by gaps in its
training if you type baboon and dolly
has learned oh we're at the
broader impact
it will generate a lot of great baboons
but if you type howler monkey and it
hasn't learned what a heller monkey is
dolly will give you its best idea of
what it thinks it could be like a
howling monkey
what's exciting about their approach
what it learned from a variety of other
labeled images and then apply it to a
new image
given a picture of a monkey dolly can
infer what it would look like doing
something
like paying its taxes while wearing a
funny hat
dolly is an example of how imaginative
humans and clever systems can work
together to make new things amplifying
our creative potential
there's a lot of hedging here open ai a
lot of hedging
against uh
against people people are criticizing
you that's good good strategy you just
hedge ahead of time you're just like hey
you can't do this you can't do that
hower monkeys are a species of monkey
that indeed howls a lot
well then it's correct right
uh
dolly 2 generates more realistic and
accurate images with 4x greater
resolution
okay a painting
in the style of claude monet of a fox
sitting in a field at sunrise well that
is indeed
a great
great
picture
yeah do you think these these things
down here are the
sort of um
initial tokens for some autoregressive
prior
i'm not sure
okay
which we currently do not make available
available in our api as part of our
effort to develop and deploy ai
responsibly for studying dali's
limitations and capabilities with a
select group of users
let me be the select group of users
oh no i'd be terrible i would be i would
be immediately cancelled
they're making it harder to share
without knowing where it's from well you
can cut just cut off the bottom
like that that's
um
safety
mitigations we have developed include
preventing harmful generations
we've limited the ability to generate
violent hate or adult images by removing
the most explicit content from the
training data okay
you also use advanced techniques to
prevent individuals facing to those of
public figures
yeah so you can
you can do you can do some things right
you can do this at training date to time
which is where you just say i'll never
expose my model to
bad things and then it doesn't learn bad
things which i don't think it can work
but not particularly well because you're
always going to miss some of that stuff
like a lot like you're gonna miss most
of that stuff
uh honestly and therefore
so either you limit your training data
to such a degree or you're going to miss
most of the stuff because the number of
ways that humans can come up with to to
do shady and things and and uh
harmful things whatever that means is
it's absolutely insane so i trust humans
to always generate things that you will
miss
and you can do it at training time so
you can if you have some sort of a
classifier that that detects uh harmful
content or whatnot you can discourage
the generation like at training time of
of these things
and then at inference time you can
obviously also filter simply if it
generates something like this you can
you can filter that out all of these
things i find sub-optimal but i do
understand that if you
want to release a product like that you
you don't want to necessarily have it
output it's already a stretch right for
a company to to
provide a service where they themselves
don't exactly know what it outputs which
is crazy with these new
apis
i understand but
uh
again they told us gpt2 was too
dangerous to release
you know you remember that
when they told us gpt2 was too dangerous
yeah so
uh curbing misuse our
content policy does not allow users okay
we won't generate images if our filters
identify text prompts and image uploads
them evaluator policies
yeah okay that that makes sense you just
tell people like don't do it
uh face development
face deployment okay previewing
limited number of trusted users
well i hope they release it at some
point not like dolly one right
there's a system card we don't care
about system cards
okay that's the blog post so for people
who've joined later this is it's pretty
insane what you can do so this is a text
to image system an astronaut playing
basketball with cats in space
in a minimalist style
insane insane
insane
yeah
and what it can do also is edit which is
going to be huge right huge for
for anyone like if this is
in some sort of photoshop or or [ __ ] or
something like this
um
new world opens for anyone who has to
make
stuff like a lot
i don't think people realize you know
how much you could you could do if you
whatever you just you have a
presentation and instead of having some
stupid stock images you just kind of
generate something and then
after generation you edit it right
the cool thing here is that you don't
have to
you don't have to
restart and figure out the prompt
exactly you can just generate something
and then edit at some point you can say
you know add this here remove this
change it to this and so on and that's
just
and and make some variations right you
can just say make some variations
and that i believe is going to be is
quite huge for a lot of people to just
use casually if that's how they intend
to release it and um
i'm very um
be very cool to see if there is an open
source replication of that
given how far we've come with clip um
and with these new data sets again for
people who haven't been here uh there is
this lion 500
m data set and
uh
people have been training
a clip models on that
oh no so lyon 400 m dataset this is the
old one there's a new 5 billion one and
if you combine that with diffusion
models
uh you can get eq like you can get
pretty insane
things as well and then if you combine
that with up sampling models then
you already have
very powerful models however i don't
know how fast they are so
the stock images of today might be the
basis of all pictures in the future yes
pretty much
i think you know we are we are probably
the generation who still
makes real images and uploads them
somewhere and before that it was just
not possible because the internet didn't
really exist in the capacity to support
that and after that most images will
just be ai generated so
um
yeah so
that's
we're we're a special generation the
last the real picture generation
okay let's just skim through the paper a
bit and and figure out how they
uh you know a bit more about what they
do
so here
super saiyan
super saiyan sentient bag of chips art
station it's
you know they're using the
okay okay um controversial opinion you
know given given that they are using
essentially discoveries of the open
source twitter community that was
explicitly explicitly a reaction to them
not releasing dali one do you think it's
appropriate that they are now using the
tricks
that that community has figured out to
make cooler images in their again
proprietary system that they don't
release and probably end up selling to
you
like
arguments for and against right but
point of contention point of contention
like
you in my opinion you know go do all the
selling you want but then
you know this is kind of the art station
at the end is a bit of a that's kind of
a thing of the the kind of sharing open
source community
and
yeah not sure
teddy bear on a skateboard in times
square this reminds me of that movie ted
no
dolphin and arrest
a dolphin in an astronaut suit on saturn
this this yeah this is 10 24 by 10 24 so
these
actually become
usable let's say in presentations and
whatnot the 256 by 256 was pushing it a
bit in terms of resolution but this
actually becomes
variations
by encoding with clip and then decoding
with the diffusion model okay okay
so this is again this is combined this
is
is this is this essentially clip based
diffusion okay here it is
hello of unclip
this is okay on clip might be the
variation thing right
that's my really
avangar
um
so is this the whole method or is this
just where you make variations
of a thing variations between two images
interpolating their clip image embedding
and then decoding with a diffusion model
we fix the decoder seed
okay
so
clip seems to play an actual role right
here right so um
they have clip here with the clip
objective right there's a text encoder
and an image encoder which they can give
in so this will give them some sort of
an embedding
and then that embedding goes
there's a prior
and then there is this
diffusion decoder
the other line we depict our text to
image generation process a clip text
embedding
is first fed into an auto aggressive or
diffusion prior to produce an image
embedding
text embedding is fed through an
auto-aggressive or diffusion prior to in
produce an image embedding
and then this embedding is used to
condition a diffusion decoder which
produces the final image note that the
clip model is frozen during training of
the prior and the decoder so there seems
to be three components right the first
component is clip itself that's above
the dotted line here
hello philip wong
good to see you here
so
and they already either have clip or
they train clip anew but they first
train clip which gives them these
embeddings of text and image right that
correspond well to each other and then
they freeze that and then there's two
more parts to it which are these this
prior thing
and the prior thing maps a text encoding
to an image encoding so the the clip
objective simply makes them align makes
these encodings align however the prior
actually transforms one into the other
it's interesting that they need that
uh and that you can't just
have the
um well i want to say have the text
encoding be the start of the
diffusion process but apparently they
put this prior here
and maybe that models that for a given
piece of text there can actually be a
lot of different
images that go along with it
but since the two
are probably already quite aligned it
might require some minor modifications
to it and then there's the diffusion
decoder right which
we saw
you can train all of this probably from
the same data sets so the clip you can
train obviously then once you have clip
you can train the prior to simply
translate the text embedding that you
get from the frozen clip encoder to the
image embedding that you can get from
the frozen clip
encoder i'm not sure if that what
happens but yeah and then you can train
the decoder likewise
simply by
encoding with clip and then trying to
reverse that process although again i
don't know if that's actually what they
do
so let's read into it
again this is the i'm seeing this for
the first time as well so i'm as
clueless
as you are does anybody have a link to
the paper you got to go to openai.com
[Music]
click on dolly and then up click on
view research
a training data set consists of pairs of
images and their corresponding captions
given an image x let z i and zt be its
clip image and text embeddings
we design our generative stack to
produce images from captions so it's
image from caption not the other way
around
using two components
a prior that produces clip image
embeddings conditioned on caption so yes
so these are these here are clip image
embeddings they're not newly trained
ones so they
the prior translates the text
encoding to the image encoding again
which is special because the clip
objective already aligns them
um during training so that again that
might require some minor
minor modifications to them it's
interesting that they have to have it
and a decoder that takes in
text captions
again
conditionally and the clip embeddings
and produces
image
condition on clip
so this is not the same if i have this
correctly as like clip guided diffusion
because in clip guided diffusion we take
a diffusion model and we feed that into
clip right
uh
let me we we take a diffusion model and
we feed that into clip
and then we
try we try to
back propagate the clip loss
to the diffusion model and try to guide
the diffusion model in this way here
it's different here
we actually
use the diffusion model but we don't
start from noise we actually start from
an embedding
that's very interesting
and i'm going to guess the
yeah the prior translates to the clip
embedding and then we start from that
that's very interesting
so the decoder yada yada yada
yada yada
okay projecting and adding clip
embeddings to the existing time step
embedding
so this is a variation of the glide
model
by projecting clip embeddings into four
and into four extra tokens of context
that are concatenated to the sequence
outputs from the text encoder
we retained the text conditioning
pathway
yada yada
but find that it offers a little help
enable classifier free guidance which is
also nice
but randomly setting clip embeddings to
zero
10 of the time and randomly dropping
text caption 50 of the time so this is a
conglomerate of sort of the recent
advances by open ai and by the community
it goes back from the decoder back into
clip
it kind of sounds like they just
modified the clip embeddings and output
via the image encoder zumba boop
yes exactly they modify
the clip embeddings via the prior first
and then via the diffusion model
okay the prior
um
to generate high resolution images we
train two diffusion up samplers one to
upsample images from this to that and
another one to further up sample them to
improve robustness we slightly corrupt
the conditioning images during training
using gaussian blur
okay
is this i i guess um
so it'd be interesting to know if this
is end to end these upsampling methods
because
to really get good generations right the
upsamplers would need to also be
informed of the
of the prompts and so on otherwise the
details are kind of generic and the big
structure is um
which is usually what you want but it's
not exactly what you want
prior
while the decoder can while the decoder
can invert clip image embeddings to
produce images we need a prior model
that produces
zi from the captions to enable image
generations from text captions
so there is an auto regressive prior
clip image embedding is
converted into a sequence of discrete
codes and predicted auto aggressively or
a diffusion prior the continuous vector
zi is directly modeled using a gaussian
diffusion model conditioned on the
caption
okay
that's cool i guess
for the diffusion prior we train a
decoder only transformer with a causal
attention mask
embedding
noise
sorry um
my reading style is not conducive to
live streaming i guess i'll adjust
so here is what how they train the loss
so the image embedding
is fed into this one
along with the time step and the text
description
the f i'm going to guess is a
noising process or something like this
and then
this is the target
so this is now a let's say true
diffusion model
where
we continuously
noise
what we want to achieve
and then we try to reverse that
variations
we are given an image we can obtain its
clip image embedding and then use our
decoder to invert
producing a new image
to make the variations more similar we
first perform this inversion with the
decoder condition on zi
okay so it it seems like clip has a big
part in this
which
is a bit surprising but not too much
because the original dali
just used clip
as a
a sort of ranker at the end whereas this
one uses clip intrinsically in the
process so it uses if it gets a piece of
text it puts it through the clip text
encoder which is frozen right and then
it has the prior and the
diffusion diffusion
exploring the clip latent space using
the unclip decoder
okay this is again the variations
variations of images featuring
typographics attack
predicted probabilities across three
labels
surprisingly the decoder still recovers
granny smith apples even when the
predictive probability of this label is
near zero percent
so what they do they project these
images into
the clip latent space and then decode
them again
can it generate text it cannot i mean it
can probably generate text as part of an
image as you can see right
here so
this is an apple
and
even though the classifier
is what kind of classifier is this
okay this is clip
so here you feed this image into clip
this was i think a famous um experiment
you feed this image into clip and you
ask clip which of the text
classes is the most likely and clip says
the ipod class is very likely
and when you actually project that and
then up sample it again
you can see that
it's interesting because clip sees
mostly an ipod right that's the class is
99.98
versus granny smith 0.02 now this is
normalized which is why i think that
this still works so they say the
surprising part right here is that it in
fact retains kind of the the apple it
retains the granny smith apple even
though technically clip mostly sees
uh the ipod but i think that's that's
kind of because it probably still sees
the apple
but when you let it classify it's just
that much closer oh sorry to the to the
ipod
text label rather than to the apple
but probably the visual information
in here like the encoding of that
is still very much
uh contains the apple motif
i guess this is what they wanna
this is what they wanna demonstrate
it's so funny how it can
this is the same thing right it's the
same thing as this this thing right here
in that it's kind of bad at spelling
like it's so interesting that it can in
fact write text even though it's an
image producing model
uh it can write text in pixels but it's
really bad at spelling
like
yeah why
nobody knows
okay let's spend a whole bunch of time
on this prior right here
um
clip image embeddings reconstruct them
with progressively more pca dimensions
okay so
we take the image on the right
i'm gonna guess
and we project it into the clip latent
space
and then we only retain the top
principal axes or the top principle
components and then we recreate them
again so there is you can investigate a
little bit what is kind of important
so it seems let me try to
make this a bit bigger
it seems like the
you can see the detail gets added as you
go up so this here is kind of a scene
from
food here you have a city that's even
might even be i don't know what city
that is i'm sorry
and the bottom one a bunch of cows this
could be switzerland
we know
so
yeah as you would expect it first tries
to model kind of the the general
framework general setting it seems to
match the colors even a little bit it's
like the colors general setting what is
it so
it's
that's really interesting right that
means the the sort of highest level
information that it has really refers to
kind of concepts
uh it does refer to color which
and and things like this but also the
concepts right so there's no
view of a cow here on the left um or
the specific city on in the middle right
here it's just like a city landscape
which is really interesting um
because
a lot of models i think they would they
would
much more try to model everything at
once but in less detail right and then
if you go down with the principal
components they would try to
just
have color blobs
everywhere
where they're relevant
and you can see as you go up as you add
principal components
what's also interesting is that as you
add principal components the scene can
radically change right so that's also
quite interesting
so here we can on the top row you can
see that we now add
we add tomatoes into the mix
so where it went from a general
or these gnocchi maybe so from a general
italian kitchen setting
it goes more and more into this
direction
and it ends up
in something that's fairly similar to
what we're seeing right and the same
here on on the bottom with the cows even
you can even see that a little bit they
have even the same same positioning but
i'm not sure if i'm over interpreting
this right here you can also see that
you have the general mountain landscape
down here and then more and more it kind
of refines to the maybe bit more correct
colors
a bit also the background gets a bit
more accurate
yeah this is it's just
quite quite cool
and as i said this is just a lot of
evidence for the fact that these things
have
some sort of abstractive representations
of what's happening
samples using different conditioning
signals for the same decoder
we passed in the first row we pass the
text caption to the decoder and pass a
zero vector for the clip embedding
in the second row we pass both the text
caption and the clip text embedding of
the caption in the third row we pass the
text and the clip image embedding
created by an auto aggressive prior for
the given caption
note that this decoder is only trained
to do the text to image generation task
without the clip image representation so
they have a lot of inputs it seems into
their decoder
so what is the first one
we pass the text caption to the decoder
so there's no text embedding from the
clip decoder or anything there's only
text caption which it also conditions on
a group and an oil painting of a corgi
wearing a party hat
hedgehog using a calculator motorcycle
parked in parking space next to another
yeah so
this as you can see the top row it picks
up kind of on like one word or so out of
the
is this intelligent is it like we should
make the meme with the butterfly
um
but as you can see it kind of
picks up on like one
one word or so out of the
uh out of the text and then it just
creates kind of a realistic image that
contains that word it doesn't it doesn't
have the
capability of fusing different things
and so on um
and i'm not sure what that is because
they say it's the same encoder and that
has been trained with various inputs and
they just pass a zero vector for the
clip embedding so they kind of stifle
the input it's not it's not a true
comparison in the sense that
they have actually trained the decoder
to only work with this type of data
so
i'm not sure what this means right here
it could mean that clip
embeddings are really important
it could also just mean that
you you have to actually train the
decoder with this because you just
stifle it from some inputs that it
doesn't have
now if you add the text embedding from
clip you can see that it already gets a
lot more capable so a hedgehog using a
calculator
yeah there is a hedgehog and there is
someone i guess using a calculator
um
motorcycle
or this wire metal rack holds several
pairs of shoes and sandals
i guess
i guess not really um
and then as as soon as you add the image
embedding as well
so that's the image embedding of
created by an autoregressive prior for
the given caption okay so the the prior
will create the image embedding
so this is the full system at the at the
bottom except
uh having a clip image embedding
um that comes from some sort of image
instead of from the prior
yeah
it's difficult to say what this means
honestly because they just take away
stuff
and obviously it's not gonna it's not
gonna
go as well
so the classifier free guidance is
um i don't actually have it
in my head exactly what it is but it's
like you
[Music]
maybe you have a classified i don't know
what they use as a classifier here maybe
clip itself
and then you can mask some stuff and
then you have the direction of where you
want to go and then you just go more
into that direction but i'm i don't have
it on top of my head what it is
okay
glide i've done a video on glide so
i don't i don't remember myself too
accurately what it does but
i love how how the different papers uh
continue this this work right so
dully
glide make a scene and then unclip green
train coming down the tracks
crazy
yeah this goes into the direction of
gans which um
just have become so good at this point
that optimizations are micro we're still
a few ways away from there but
it's getting there
samples from unclip and glide for the
prompt
a red cube on top of blue cube
yeah pretty good
reconstructions from the decoder for
difficult
binding problems we find that the
reconstructions mix up objects and
attributes in the first two examples the
model mixes up the color of two objects
in the rightmost example the model is
not reliably reconstruct the relative
size of the two objects
yeah so probably
you know given
this might also be a property right of
the of the text descriptions maybe not
the binding problem as much but the
relative sizes you
rarely
have a text description that describes
the relative sizes of things and
therefore the encodings might just end
up with sort of what's contained in the
image
and
then
that's what the models learn that okay
what's mostly important is what's
contained
a sign that says deep
deep deep
this is just deep deep
deep deep
come on
high quality photo of a dog playing in a
green field next to lake
unclip samples showing low
levels of detail for some complex scenes
okay
yeah so
um
dolly 2 oh dolly 2 and unclip seem to be
the same model right so that just
because i was i was wondering
um
i was wondering sort of
because they kept talking about on on
clip
but i do believe that um
dolly 2
is on clip oh correct me if i'm wrong
right here
but here they describe it yes this is on
on clip that's dolly too
this thing right here
so yeah i don't i don't know what to
what to think of this um it's certainly
super
impressive what it can do right if you
if you look at
oh there's join waitlist okay okay we'll
do that
um
it's certainly super impressive like the
applications of this are i believe quite
far-reaching because this allows
more and more
yeah it decouples
i think the mechanical
i've already said this i think in the
past it decouples the mechanical skill
of making these things happen like the
photoshop skill or the painting skill
or or nunchuck skills
uh
fighting skills
it decouples the mechanical skills
uh from
or it decouples them from the creativity
part
so usually you have like okay i wanna do
something
and then the second thing is okay i have
to have to actually implement it and
this thing decouples it it kind of takes
that mechanical aspect away from you and
therefore
you're left to focus on what should
happen and i think with these editing
capabilities that it can do and the
variation capabilities this could be
very powerful if built into if built
into [ __ ]
um
and then in [ __ ] you can just say okay
enter text a piece of text
create an image okay edit here enter
piece of text
make some variations on this thing right
here select a bunch of stuff
very very powerful
and i guess a lot of people would pay a
lot of money for it which might be the
end goal here all right i hope you
enjoyed this kind of live reaction
um
live reaction to this
type of research i'm excited to see if
this actually ever gets out here
um
but yeah
let me know how you like this type of
stuff if we do live reactions in the
future again
and yeah i'll i guess i'll see you
around thank you very much for being
here i'll stop the stream now bye-bye